[Music]
in not-so-subtle Japanese submitted by
yoga fire yoga flame forever 21 cent
Atkins diet bars along with customer
orders and got people pissed they got
pissed from free products because people
were probably like what the [ __ ] your
tummy into this way I need to go on a
diet
yeah I'd be like thank you for the
cookie yeah that means I'm not Asian
because Asians like free [ __ ] yeah yeah
I mean I wouldn't have thought about
only Asians like free [ __ ] well these
people got mad mad no only agents like
free should I just say would you get
offended if they sent you a protein bars
right it's probably that's probably
who's getting upset I would get upset
too
yeah they're saying that so here's one
of epi everyone getting the [ __ ] my mom
ordered some clothes from Forever 21's
plus-size collection and they sent an
Atkins diet bar along with the stuff she
ordered did I send it with everyone's
order or the pleasure 21 is claiming
that they sent it to everyone but as far
as I've seen it's people complaining are
the ones that got the Plus Size that is
[ __ ] incredible this is incredible
trolling yeah so like waking up what do
you want to say um so I X a CD
underscore can we please get this
trending my friend ordered plus size
clothes from clothes and at forever 21
sent her an Atkins diet bar call
customer service and they won't do
anything what do they want to take the
Atkins bar back forever sort of watch
the center a [ __ ] diet shake so I
think what that what that was trying to
do is like stop it from continuing oh
they call them to say I wouldn't be
pissed
I'd be like working I didn't get my
protein bar you have some [ __ ] [ __ ]
complained and I'm like man you [ __ ]
up my poaching Bosh why do they have
like a brand new with this protein bar
do they just white hella protein bars
you know
I'm sure they're not giving it away for
free yeah okay um so another person said
yes shame on me for ordering from two at
forever 21 but why do they have to push
diet food on me it came with an Atkins
or would they be mad if I was like Hot
Cheetos good question his sleep it would
have been like hell yeah you know I'm
fat girl baby like thanks for 20 like
okay well people have been are you
calling me fat where are you sending me
like snacks like is like I get it like
the problem is a diet food but like I
just wonder like do you [ __ ] up if you
send anything like a clip like what if
you say thank you you know like it's how
sensitive people are people are just
sensitive I think I'd be pissed too
if you sent him a Carvel ice cream cake
who's gonna be pissed what you don't
know ice cream cakes no they're
delicious
all right so if every Toni one apologize
and so the promo went to all customers
like I mentioned earlier is that quote
from time to time forever 21 surprises
our customers with free test products
from third parties in their e-commerce
orders yeah I remember freebie items in
question were included in all online
orders across all sizes and categories
for a limited time and have since been
removed this was an oversight on our
part and we sincerely apologize for any
offense this may have caused to our
customers this was not our intention in
any way so what if a skinny girl gets a
package and she's like so what you're
saying I need to eat well it's like no
like I am well it's like saying like for
example like I'm pretty normal size and
if like I said earlier if I would have
gotten I wouldn't have been upset but
that's also because I don't understand
what bigger girls go through by people
telling them you're unhealthy or you are
like you need to lose weight or whatever
the case may be no voting in that that
section and the big they go oh let's not
send it to the big girls right and then
the big girls realize hey how come you
guys got a freaking cookie and I didn't
screw up well you saying that I don't
even need to eat no more because I'm too
fat so you just never win well I mean
they should have explained it like if it
was a if it was a for everybody
collaboration or something they just
send it to everyone zero discrimination
guys get it to everyone and then he just
explained it okay you go card yeah yeah
hey this is to sell
how we were able to collab with such a
cool company Atkins here we want to
share the whatever try it out if they
just wanted a surprise you just go oh
what I don't understand is how did they
come to this conclusion on their own
like oh my mom is fat that's why she got
this Atkins bar because of the plus-size
section shopping and I think you're
right yeah I think it wasn't as
something right I think it isn't as
something because I would automatically
assume like oh cool they're working with
Atkins we would right but that girl was
I think trolling her mom cuz when she
tweeted she put the little skulls like
I'm dying laughing she was like my mom
does a picture yeah like shares a little
skull like me that means like I'm
[ __ ] dying of slaw that's sure I
totally ignore the emoji yeah so it'd be
better if there's like two butter
fingers in there it's dead I know I
think what Joe was saying it's just an
assumption that that was made maybe
maybe you get an option on the website
it says do you want flamin hot cheetos
or do you want to act but that's not a
surprise anymore
I agree but you're not a performing
tomorrow no matter what you shouldn't
give fat people food cuz it's dangerous
[Laughter]
as a promo item know if your clothing
company right don't give fat people food
if you're a food company give them food
John said why would you try to add to
the problem by joking trying to say what
are you trying to say just gonna clip
your like repeating that like alright no
okay so if you're not a company that is
about food right like let's say like if
you're a restaurant or whatever right
you really don't have much business
giving away free food waiter extra but
if you're not a business that serves
food so like let's say I'm a shoe
company or whatever right why given free
food it's odd contain you like how much
are they paying you
yeah we have some free bars but I don't
know or like if you're yeah or if you're
a couch company right like your couch
company you're giving free cookie unless
it's a collab with like hot cheetos and
a couch is made out of
that makes it yeah but when they did the
Hot Cheetos think about 21 did that they
didn't send it like they had apparel
that was hot cheetos they like Brandon
like with like influencers you know
something if they do that and that's the
only time it makes sense yeah true true
yeah cuz I'm feels like what you guys
were mentioning earlier I've never
received a single Ruby from forever 21
me neither
ever not whatever well I think it's okay
to do if it's ironic like this as long
as it's perfect irony yeah so the other
girl she tweeted I went from a size 24
to 18 still a plus-size girl so I
ordered Jade's from forever 21 open the
package when I looked inside I see this
Atkins bar what are you trying to tell
me forever 21 anyone else's mouth that's
not Plus yeah that's what I'm saying I
haven't seen anyone that actually
happened where it was like they're fat
they need a [ __ ] they need a protein
bar go on a diet right this is gonna
make them happy they send that [ __ ] and
it backfires and they go no we send it
to everybody yeah that'll be [ __ ]
hilarious probably what happened is
they're so artists are people upset
because of the possible subliminal
message it's an absolute I don't think
it's that subliminal about this what if
this what if Sean John sent their
clothes with [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah it's
like a Tommy Bahama but I know you're
saying no but let's say they said Sean
John with like with some swim lessons
would that be a [ __ ] loss right now
Sean John is the urban market right
black people it's a stereotype they
can't swim so I'm John with the snorkel
is that is that is it when people get
pissed Oh what are you trying to say I
can't [ __ ] this way it's the same thing
like you need to learn how to such a
nice thing to give somebody that's what
I think it's free food
have a have a story so um so I had this
boyfriend was he cries oh I know their
story yeah you know her but tell me okay
so he would always complain about his
weight and like you know just he was
always like all about exercise I got
healthier but he never did what does
this car seat look like flattened that's
not the point of her story try to
understand the guy well he likes food
yeah and he doesn't like to exercise so
yeah yeah I mean it's gonna happen
uh-huh and um so well okay so this guy
he wasn't like big all around it was
just mainly like the like his legs and
his arms looked normal
it was just like mainly the middle
portion was bigger so he was like a
pillow with arms I mean funny yeah
exactly and so um one Christmas I
thought I was doing something nice to
see what one time you mentioned that he
really wanted this one product that it's
like a waistband down you got him a
sweaty waistband thing and I got hurt
you gotta Spanx no I sweat like two more
cowboy without moving kinda thing and so
I'm like well he doesn't like moving she
wants to lose weight he said he liked
this product so I got it for him for
Christmas he got so mad at me so much
weight but he asked for it that's what
these rooms feel I swear to god ask for
it he just said he wanted it he wanted
it he didn't ask that's the same as
wanting it maybe maybe he was like I'm
gonna tell TIFF that I feel so
uncomfortable being fat so she could
tell me no babe you look great I love
you just the way you are and you're
gonna do that that's what else I call
it's not just a sensitive person was a
sign sign the porn sites party part this
is his birthday June 31st
no he's a counter that's why he's fat
skorpa corn he sounds like a cancer not
the [ __ ] astrology's ones either
yourself skinny thinkin I love you I
just don't understand that come in he's
just oh that he was like that like he
wanted the
kind of like girly things girl yes I
agree like guys do that too but I guess
like what's known as like that's a girl
thing to do no guys do that too but it
depends on what they care about
so like guys like you know like I mean
they might want compliments in like
their abilities and something girl thing
yeah but here it is this fad which I
think a lot of girls can relate to the
fad thing yeah so then every time that
huge nothing a lot of girls can relate
just [ __ ] you're having a homerun
Derby today all-star game I'm not wrong
to say things that I observed that's
honest well it hurts people please don't
stop I think it's the somme the Whitney
say it it's uh there's not enough
explanation and I think because you're
so comfortable with us we get you we
know your history maybe you forget
people are like yeah the cameras are off
it's not my fault that they're stupid
and they're taking the most basic
explanation for things instead of I
don't know you're talking about them or
fat women five minutes isn't it a trope
though that women are insecure about
their weight most not all those were my
words I said most women can relate to
that magazine exactly it's just yeah
yeah and what's wrong with saying the
honest truth about things I think I was
just laughing cuz Steve pointed but I
don't get it no I don't understand I
just know there's some girl out there I
didn't say all women I just said most
women can't relate to that insecurity
which is a weight issue I don't know
there's someone out there and she's got
a table Briers in her lap and she's
pretty much enjoying the [ __ ] out of
this video yeah that guy um he was like
so he would be very big and grandiose
you know I mean like I meant to say like
you know in our first year of being
together every month he would go like
all out and give me like a big old
bouquet of flowers
this stuff and I'm like well that's so
nice like that's every girl wants that
right yeah so but it was annoying as
[ __ ] because like you think every girl
wants yeah yeah yeah
so then um no it wasn't cuz of that but
then he would react in a way where it's
like so where's my big ol grand gesture
what a scumbag [ __ ] that's what you
say no this big no it's like because he
would like make things on his own kind
of thing and he would be like aren't you
gonna make something for me like that
has a lot of me you don't have no skill
oh it's romantic you know what this is
the kind of guy that takes longer than
the girl in the bathroom to get ready
you don't want to be out needed' you
know I'm saying like I think that's
that's when you kinda you know what like
I guess if you wanted someone like that
and that just wasn't ya you'll find
everyone else that's what I'm saying
about him have a partner that is like
that in that love language is different
yeah it's different but I think it
doesn't matter what gender you are to
expect it and put in the work to expect
something out of it is what's wrong yeah
I don't know if it's like that it could
also be something where it's like you
think that both of you value the same
thing when you don't well it is if he
really was he really was like what Joe
just said because I think he'll do
favors for other people and then be like
what are you gonna do for me it's
selfish work he's putting in work hoping
that you will return it instead of just
communicating to you like hey this kind
of stuff makes me happy
exactly which is the right thing to do
but it's difficult cuz you have to be
vulnerable about it did you ever come
home and you're like here's some
balloons I guess I've tried I'll try
seemed like he was five years older than
me how you felt 10 years younger than
your team so he was what 24 yeah that's
crazy man yeah that was an interesting
relationship but then I felt so shitty
that I gave him that thing because I'm
like did I [ __ ] up
he's like it doesn't fit oh no naku than
that
hey but now you don't actually now you
can understand what some guys go through
when they when they hear like oh that's
gonna be a great gift and then they get
it and then they're like I [ __ ] up you
know some people do that I'm thinking
about right now that sorry Casey
but um so because I remember I went to
it when he would not really sing sorry
because I remember when he would tell me
like yeah I'm so fat whatever my
response was you know let's go work out
or like let's go ride a bike and that's
what Casey tells me now and I feel like
damn I wait I gain weight and then I get
mad at him for telling me about things
but now you know how mr. Cho sounds
moves you have to be guilty to feel
empathy I learned that the hard way
yeah sorry way to own your [ __ ] that's
tight good job he's very pleased
[Music]